Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
Where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their business.
Both: Get ready, Sharks!
Here comes TROBO!
If you're
anything like us,
your pet is
a member of your family.
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
Wow, you've got everything
in there.
...they'll invest
their own money
and fight each other
for a deal.
I'm gonna make you
a contingent offer.
Are you serious?
Do not invest
more money in this.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs must
get the full amount
They're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
Sales is not our expertise.
We're advertising guys.
-No.
-Really?
You want to give us a little bit
of a better valuation?
Uh, you want to take
that gamble?
It's like
I'm in an alternate world.
Harden: This is
what I'm offering to you --
a dude who's got fire in his
belly like you've never seen!
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Daymond John dominated
the fashion world with FUBU.
Now he's the branding expert
behind multiple global brands
generating billions in sales.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank are
unique and stylish accessories
for the most important member
of the family.
Oh!
Hi, Sharks.
My name Steven Blustein.
And I'm Sean Knecht.
Both: And we're the founders
of PrideBites pet products.
We are seeking $200,000
for 10% of our company.
If you're
anything like us,
your pet is
a member of you family.
And because of that,
we believe
that they should be spoiled
in a way
that is
completely unique.
So let me introduce you
to PrideBites.
We allow you to design,
customize, and buy
anything you want
for you furry friend,
providing one-of-a-kind products
for your one-of-a-kind pet.
So, like Sadie here,
in her personalized collar,
your dog can truly feel like
man's best friend.
Our process is
incredibly simple.
First, select from one
of the high-quality products
on our website.
Next, pick the size,
color, pattern,
and design
of your choice.
Finally, add
your personal paw-print
by including
your pet's name
or even one of our amazing,
hand-drawn portraits.
-[ Giggles ]
-In just a few weeks,
your items will be delivered
right to your door.
So, Sharks, which one of you is
ready to get your paws dirty
and to join us
on proving more choices
for our
four-legged friends?
Sadie, high ten!
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-Aww.
-So, Sean's gonna go ahead
and hand out our custom stuff
that we made for all of you.
Aww, what's
the dog's name?
-Thank you. Hey, baby.
-The dog's name is Sadie.
[ Smooches ]
Hey. Aww, she's adorable.
All right. Sorry.
-So, this is yours...
-Thank you very much.
-...for your dog Lola.
Aww!
-For you.
-Thank you.
Is this a toy?
-Yes, ma'am.
-Look at this.
-Very attractive.
Greiner:
Oh, it's a Frisbee.
It looks like her!
Yeah, so, that was
actually a picture
that we took from your dog,
and then one of our hand --
our designers hand-draws
everything...
-Very cool. Thank you.
-...to match your portrait.
That's really good.
Yeah,
thank you very much.
[ Toy squeaks ]
So, what are
the price ranges?
Uh, we range from $9.99
all the way up to $150.
So, you guys are Shutterfly
for pet products.
Sure. So, this is
where we differ
from Shutterfly,
actually.
With Shutterfly,
you're just putting
a picture on a blanket.
We actually custom-manufacturer
from scratch.
You're the designer,
so think of it as a blank slate.
So, you to pick a red blanket,
customizing the trim,
uh, you put
your monogram in.
So, I order today.
When will I receive the product?
So the turnaround time right now
is within four weeks,
but we have all the solutions
in place
to drop it down
to two weeks and one week.
Where are you manufacturing
and doing this all out of?
Everything is done overseas,
and what we've built is
this amazing
proprietary system
that allows us to organize
the whole customization process
and allows us
to scale efficiently.
And so, typically
you're not able to deliver
the margins
to direct to consumer
with customized products,
but we've actually built
this system that allows the
factories to work seamlessly.
So, walk us
through the margins, Steven.
Yeah, absolutely, so,
the margin's
about 50% landed
to -- to the consumer.
And, so,
what are your sales?
You've been doing it
for how long?
About 2 1/2 years.
Sales to date are
$1.4 million.
Whoa!
Wow.
This year, we're on pace
to do $1.3 million.
-Good for you.
-Nice.
-Thank you very much.
-Is it all online?
-No, it's not actually.
-Oh, it's not?
We've had sales for brands
and retailers, as well,
that make about 70%.
Wait.
Explain that to me.
Explain where 70%
of your business comes from.
Yeah, 70% is to brands
and retailers
who want
a customized product.
We've been prototyping
custom kiosks within store
so that people can come in
and customize on the spot.
To improve
the customer experience.
But, Steven, you can't be making
50 points on the retail.
What's your margin
on the retail?
On the retail,
it's 40 points.
How did you come up
with this idea?
We started
in our college apartment.
Uh, we really built it up.
-[ Smooches ]
We literally started selling
these dog toys door-to-door
and going
to football tailgates.
We literally sold
everywhere.
And we sold this product called
the "Pride Bite."
-Which one?
-This -- This toy.
The pizza?
We started out with
a standard, classic toy.
[ Toy squeaks ]
Knecht: It won
Dog Toy of the Year.
[ Toy squeaking ]
It floats. It squeaks --
machine washable.
It's one of the most
versatile toys on the market.
Guys, let me get
the ball rolling here.
Look, you've done
a great job.
The challenge is
there's not really
a barrier
to entry there.
I-I think it's gonna be a very,
very challenging business.
I just don't think
I can help you scale.
I think it's going
to be difficult.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
-Okay.
-Thank you for your time.
I think you're
a little expensive in valuation
because this is
a customized commodity play
in pet products, which is
a pretty big market, I think.
Pet market is big --
$80 billion.
Well, I think
dog pizza slices aren't
going to fit
in my portfolio.
I'm not really moved
by it.
I'm out.
Greiner: So...
you haven't really been selling
that much online,
but the whole big,
unique thing about you is
the whole
customization thing...
Right.
...that you're going
and doing online.
Yeah, so, we actually took
3,500 orders
in the first 90 days.
And it was the run to say,
"Hey, we've gone
from doing customization
within store.
We know
that we can do it in store.
What does online feel?"
We launched online with a site,
took 3,500 orders --
You've got to do
more online.
-Right.
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
-Now it's our focus.
-And so now it's our pure focus.
Herjavec: What I really like
about it is the fact that you --
you've really figured
something out at this scale
where you can do small runs
and do it efficiently.
Yeah.
The timeframe's
a bit of a problem.
I don't know if people are
that patient to wait,
but you say
you're gonna cut that down.
-Absolutely.
-That's the big --
So, we're making
that shift now because --
No, no, I got it.
You're gonna get there,
and I think I can help
you with that.
And we have a great team.
Absolutely.
With that, um...
I think you're --
We know you're a pet guy.
We know it.
And I love dogs!
My offer is
$200,000 for 20%.
Well, thank you very much
for that offer.
Thank you.
We really appreciate it.
Guys, so this very --
this is very impressive.
I like your logistics.
My biggest challenge is
that your --
your not there online,
and the area
that I don't want to go into is
the premium market
of selling tchotchke stuff
to big stores
and big outlets.
So, at this point,
I don't think it's for me.
I'm out.
Thank you very much
for your time.
Thank you for your time.
So, three Sharks are out.
So, my question is
are you willing to negotiate
a little bit
on the equity portion
and come down
to meet us at 15%?
Make me a counter.
Uh, so --
Greiner: I haven't made you
my offer yet.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Steven and Sean have one offer
on the table from Robert --
$200,000 for 20% equity in their
customized-pet-product business,
PrideBites.
But Lori says
she wants to make an offer.
So, my question is
are you willing to negotiate
a little bit
on the equity portion
and come down to --
to meet us at 15%?
Make me a counter.
Uh, so --
Greiner: I haven't made you
my offer yet.
Ooh!
Interesting!
And I'd like
to make you an offer.
Okay. Please.
Because I like
your style.
-Thank you very much.
-I like the look.
-Thank you.
-I think it's very cute.
I've sold a lot of personalized
things over the years.
I know a lot my customers
really love to personalize.
Yeah.
So, I'm going to make you
an offer of $200,000 at 18%.
Uh, Robert, is there any counter
there within you could bring?
-Ohh!
Would you all be willing
to join together?
To join together.
What if we did
$300,000 for 20%
and you guys came in
together?
Such a deal!
You can't turn that down.
$300,000 for how much?
Uh, $300,000 for 20%.
So, $300,000 for 20%, you're
saying $1.5 million value.
With two Sharks, yeah.
With two Sharks.
You came in
at a $2 million value...
$300,000 for 30%.
Uh, 20%.
Sorry.
$300,000 for 30%.
20%.
15% each --
You've got two Sharks,
and you've got more cash.
-$300,000 for 30%.
I would do that.
If we could calm down
to 20%,
we would make a deal
right now.
We'd love to work
with you guys.
Both of you.
You'll get something --
We promise you,
we will never sleep.
We hustle.
$200,000 for 20%.
-Two Sharks?
-Two Sharks.
-All right, y'all got a deal.
-Deal.
-Done.
-Awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Wait a minute.
Well, are you in?
We were at $300,000
for 30% a minute ago?
Right, and we dropped it
to $200,000 for 20%.
And Robert jumped up
and said "deal"?
-With both -- both of you.
-I thought -- I thought both
of y'all were coming in
on it.
We would love --
Two Sharks are better than one.
We would love two Sharks.
Lori's doing a little
Michael Jackson moonwalk on you.
All right,
I'll tell you what --
If Lori doesn't do it,
I'll do it with Robert,
and you'll have
two Sharks.
No. I'm in.
-Yes! All right!
-Awesome!
-My God!
-Yes! Thank you so much!
[ Laughter ]
Yay!
-Thank you.
-Did you really want the deal,
Herjavec: or you just wanted
to screw Kevin?
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
-[ Laughs ]
We appreciate it.
Thank y'all so much.
Knecht: Come on, let's go!
Hey, grab your leash!
Grab your leash.
Let's go!
Let's go.
Yes, dude, yes!
Oh, my God.
Blustein: I think having
two Sharks, you don't only get
all the skills
and the traits
from what Robert brings
to the table...
Yeah.
...but also, um,
the amazing presence
that Lori has, as well.
And in combination
with our team,
we feel like we can
take over the world,
essentially,
in the pet world.
Kevin, throw the Frisbee!
Kevin!
Are you kidding?
This is incredibly valuable!
Throw the Frisbee!
No!
I don't want to damage it.
Here you go!
Here you go, Robby!
[ Laughter ]
I'm at the Orgill Dealer Market
in Orlando.
It's a huge trade show,
and 10 of my "Shark Tank"
entrepreneurs are here.
The Scrub Daddy is
actually lab-tested
to not hold odors
for up to two months.
Greiner: Having all my companies
in one section is like
a magnet for retail buyers.
Before I partnered
with these businesses,
their combined sales were
about $8 million.
Since I've invested,
total sales are $188 million.
Well, here's
how easy it works --
Man: Sometimes, you can't
even get buyers on the phone,
but at this trade show
you get to meet them,
and you actually close the sale
right there in person.
Put the strip right on,
hit it with the blow dryer,
and that's it.
Woman: Each trade show gives us
a chance to interact
with our customers
and get real feedback
on what
they're looking for.
And I just got hacked.
Well, if you'd had this,
it wouldn't have happened.
Man: This is
my first trade show ever,
but being in her section
with the rest
of her entrepreneurs gives me
a ton of confidence.
-Can I give you one of these?
-Yes.
Man: It feels great
to be in Lori's section.
I feel like
the coolest kid in school.
Everybody wants
to come talk to you.
So, feel that.
Man: Face-to-face interaction
fuels excitement and loyalty.
They go back to their stores
invigorated to sell Scrub Daddy.
-We're doing really well.
-High five!
Man: This has been
a killer show.
We got so much new business,
I don't know how to keep up.
Well, we're gonna lower
the price here.
We already sold tens
of thousands of dollars
at this trade show.
-It's 1,000 degrees here.
-Wow!
Man: We've already sold
over $15,000 of product,
and it's only the first day.
Spread the word.
Woman: It's been a real
privilege doing business
with Lori.
It really has put us
on the map.
Excited to do business
with you. Thank you.
Us, too.
She has such a great sense
for business,
and she's just
an incredible mentor.
So proud of all of you!
Greiner: There isn't much more
I could ask for as an investor.
They've done sales that many
people wish to do in a lifetime.
This is truly a dream come true.
All: Team Lori!
Narrator: Next up is a modern
version of a traditional toy.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Chris Harden.
And I'm Jeremy Scheinberg,
and we're the creators of TROBO,
the storytelling robot
from Orlando, Florida,
and we're seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 10% of our company.
How many times have you heard
a stuffed toy repeat
the same mindless phrases
over and over and over again?
And it ends up at the bottom
of that toy box after two weeks
never to be played with
again.
Well, not anymore.
Introducing TROBOs.
TROBOs are
wirelessly connected,
cuddly toys
that read stories
about science and math
to children
using tablets
and phones.
Children
not only read along,
but they also interact
with questions
and puzzles
along the way.
The stories are
personalized,
and the TROBO even calls
your child by name.
We go one step further
by actually putting
the child
right into the story.
The child builds
an avatar within the app
and quickly becomes
the main character.
Okay, Daymond --
Time to come on down and meet
your new best friend, Newton.
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
Harden: Your adventure today,
on the TV here, is
"What do Sharks Eat?"
-[ Laughs ]
-Aww.
-Have a seat right here.
[ Laughing ] Good luck getting
out of that stool.
You can turn around
to the Sharks if you like.
-[ Laughs ]
-Aww.
Harden: Here's your pal.
Isn't he sweet?
[ Chuckles ]
Hit the right arrow
to get started.
TROBO: Daymond, did you know
some sharks will eat anything?
This poor shark has
a tummy ache
from all the trash
she's eaten.
Help her feel better
by dragging all the items
from her tummy
to the garbage can.
Harden: There you go.
Drag it right over.
Perfect.
There you are.
He's doing great, isn't he?
-[ Laughs ]
John: Can I keep this?
You can't.
[ Laughter ]
You have to complete
the puzzle to move forward.
All right, take
a little sippy, "Pookie."
[ Laughter ]
TROBO: You did it.
You made her tummy ache
go away.
All right.
Thank you so much, Daymond.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-Instead of landing
at the bottom
of the toy bin,
with our growing
content library,
TROBO's become the companions
and the teachers
that stick around
year after year.
And parents get a head start
on teaching science
and math in the home.
Both: Get ready, Sharks.
Here comes TROBO.
Okay, these are
personalized TROBOs.
They have
a little embroidered tag
at the back
with your names on them.
-Thank you.
-Yes.
Hmm, thank you.
-There you go.
-Aww.
-Isn't that lovely?
-[ Chuckling ] "Lori's TROBO."
-Very cute.
-Thank you.
Harden: It's more special
than the first one you had.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-They're very cuddly.
This is where
the sound comes out of.
Both: Exactly.
I can't control
the tablet from here.
Harden: Correct.
So, the only purpose
of TROBO,
besides being lovable
and cuddly, is sound?
He's a speaker.
He's a speaker, but really
it's an emotional connection
between the child and
the stories and the content.
Who creates
the content, Jeremy?
It's actually
very interesting.
We actually crowd source
the content.
So we throw out
a story topic,
and that --
We have a story contest.
People submit stories,
and we pay
for the story content.
That's a good idea.
How much
is TROBO gonna cost?
Uh, retail is $59.95 for the toy
and the first five stories.
Ooh.
What are your sales?
We have several buyers
who have placed orders.
We're talking
with manufacturers, reps,
mainly towards
mid-box retail.
What orders do you got
in place?
We've gotten some small
boutique orders at this point.
How much would it come up
to be about?
Uh, we have the total number
of orders of 600 units.
600 units -- And how many
shows did you attend
to get those 600 units?
Two.
We attended two.
Trade shows.
Did any of them show
great interest?
We did not get
that kind of response
because we were dealing
with boutique and lower volume.
There's so many learning apps
and, uh, you know,
smart plush toys
in the market.
What do you think
differentiates you?
We've been covered
in 45 publications,
TVs, magazines,
you name it.
If you only have
600 orders...
-Mm-hmm.
-...and you have
45 publications
write you up,
why did the stores
not support that?
They really -- They seemed
to be averse to risk to us.
And we'll be straight
with you.
This is a year and a half
into the industry for us.
We have a lot of skills
in manufacturing and execution,
but this is new for us.
It's one reason why
we're here -- for you guys.
Herjavec: Chris, walk me
through the process.
Is there a monthly fee
I pay to get more stories?
$4.95 per story,
and then we're gonna switch
to a subscription model.
I think if you can get
critical mass,
you actually become a
very valuable marketing channel
for a large branch trying
to sell to those kids.
Basically, the plush toy is
your way to capture the child.
-Exactly. You get it.
-Yes. Yes.
Guys, I'm not a fan
of the idea.
To me, this is
all about content, right?
The content's
all that matters.
Unless it makes the kid go
"wow," you know,
and just was
really compelling,
and I just didn't see that
from there.
And so, you know, I don't see it
as this big blow-up,
go-out-and-crush-it type
of idea, so I'm out.
You can't sell a $50 plush toy
with a speaker in it.
That's not gonna work.
The actual content, at $4,
that's not gonna work.
There's tons
of free content
for everybody
for children's books --
free, no cost.
Having come
from this space,
you need Target,
you need Walmart to play
in the toy space
to get huge volumes.
They're not gonna put that
on the shelf for $50 bucks.
It's not gonna work.
I'm out.
Have you heard
of Teddy Ruxpin?
Back in '85, Teddy Ruxpin
sold for $70 a unit.
He sold $95 million.
-Yeah, but his mouth moved,
eyes -- Uh, it was --
It was a different time
when technology wasn't
at, you know, at it's level.
The direction you're going,
I don't --
I think you're gonna hit
a dead road.
I'm sorry about that.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Daymond.
I think the $60 price point is
a challenge.
I also listened
to the experts.
When you went
to Toy Fair,
you didn't have
people jumping on board
from any of the large retailers
to get this in.
And usually, when they see
something that's new,
innovative,
and excites them,
they're all over it.
So, I take that
as a caution,
as a warning
to me as an investor.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Robert,
before you begin --
We haven't talked
about passion.
And I believe
that's something
that you guys look for
regularly in your teams.
Because I think
it's important.
You're looking at a guy
who was a kid on welfare.
I was one of three children
to a mom.
My father died
when I was 6 years old.
She had alcohol problems.
She ended up going to prison.
I learned a very valuable lesson
from my mom.
She told me if I could stick to
my education day in and day out,
I would get out from that,
and I have.
I focused on hard work
and education,
so I am a believer
in education.
This is what I'm offering
to you --
Two guys who can execute
like nobody's business,
and a dude who's got fire in his
belly like you've never seen!
[ Laughs ]
I'm asking you
to think about that.
Herjavec: Chris, I --
I'd like to ask
all of you guys to reconsider.
Chris, thank you
for sharing that.
Thanks
for you passion.
You know,
when I was in university --
I quit university
after my first year.
And I was sitting home
one day, and my dad,
who worked in a factory
his whole life --
Nobody had ever gotten
past high school
in my entire family,
so my dad sees me at home
and says,
"What you doing home?"
I go, "Ah, nothing.
Just watching TV.
I, uh, dropped
out of school."
So, he looks at me quitely,
and he says,
"You know I love you.
I kill you, bury you backyard.
Nobody ever find body.
Go back to school."
-[ Laughs ]
And I went back to school.
So, it's really important.
I -- Let me tell you
where I'm at,
and, uh...
Work with us, Robert.
I actually didn't --
It didn't
make me go "wow"
in the application
that Daymond was using it.
So...
I don't really see it
as a toy.
I see it
as a content-delivery business.
It really comes down
to the content.
We have an amazing relationship
with DreamWorks.
They want to go in retail.
They want to sell product.
They have amazing content.
I think that they would do
a licensed deal.
I see it as a way
for them to sell content
and a way
to sell plush animals
and some more Shreks and
all kinds of other characters.
I could broker that meeting.
We'll walk in with you.
So, I'll make you
an offer.
I'll give you $100,000
for 1/3 of the business.
That's my offer.
Is this contingent
on you landing a deal?
It's contingent
on DreamWorks picking it up
as a licensed product.
-Why would DreamWorks need
these guys to do
any of this?
Herjavec: It's a different way
to deliver content.
No, anybody can do
a plush doll.
Yeah, but you know what?
Anybody can do it. But these
guys have figured it out.
It's a connection
between the plush animal...
Well, I don't know
about that.
...and the online store.
-Well, you guys --
-Hey, I'm selling slippers
in the shape of Shrek,
and we're selling millions
of dollars' worth.
This is a way
to sell content.
Harden: And we appreciate
your offer.
We -- We have a hard time
with the valuation.
Would you consider going
to $166,000
for a 1/3 of our company?
That's
a $500,000 valuation.
Ooh.
So, you came in asking
for $100,000.
You're counter
to me is $166,000?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
For the 1/3.
Um...
Sure.
Welcome
to team TROBO, Robert!
All right, thank you, guys.
We'll set up the meeting.
-I mean, I --
-Congrats, guys.
We're excited.
We really are very excited!
-Yeah, thank you very much.
-Thank you so much.
Bring it in.
-Cheers, guys.
[ Laughs ]
-All right, thank you so much.
-Good luck, guys.
-Congrats, guys.
-It seems obvious to me.
-Bye, Sharks. Thank you so much.
Greiner: Bye.
Thank you.
Cuban: Congrats.
Right?
-All right.
-Ugh!
TROBO,
what are you saying?
[ High-pitched voice
Robert, you're screwed!
[ Laughs ]
[ High-pitched voice ]
Kevin, you don't know anything.
[ Laughs ]
It's never gonna work!
[ Imitates crying ]
[ Laughter ]
-I'm Van.
-And I'm Sheldon.
Gould: And we're
from New York City.
[ Elevator bell dings ]
We met in grad school,
and we now work
at an ad agency.
Sheldon: Our society has
a serious problem
where people are focused
way too much on their phones
and not enough
on each other.
You know, everywhere you go,
people are just starting
down at that screen --
on the streets,
in the parks, in
the restaurants --
especially Sheldon.
You know, I think there's a few
things we need to talk about.
[ Cellphone rings ]
Oh, hold on a second.
Gould: It's crazy.
And that's when we realized
what a huge problem this was.
Sheldon: And that's
when we came up with our idea.
What do you think
of that?
I think that could work.
[ Horn honks ]
Gould: We designed our concept,
and it really works.
Look, we know
how crazy-fun dependency can be.
But with our product,
anyone can get past it.
And once we put
our idea online,
we received
thousands of e-mails
from people who desperately
wanted our product.
With the Sharks' help,
we can get this product
in the hands
of millions of Americans.
We believe a day, an hour,
or even five minutes
with no phone can really bring
the world together.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is
Chris Sheldon.
And I'm Van Gould.
We're seeking $25,000
for 15% equity in our company.
There's a huge problem
in the world right now.
And it's called...
Both: Phone addiction.
A recent report found
that 79% of adults have
their cellphones with them
22 hours a day.
People are driving
with their phones,
sleeping
and even going on dates
with their phones.
Some people can't
even stop looking
at their phones
while they're on TV.
[ Laughter ]
But don't worry, Sharks.
We have the solution.
Introducing --
Da-dum.
-The NoPhone.
The NoPhone is
a technology-free alternative
to constant
hand-to-phone contact.
It's a fake phone for people
addicted to real phones.
[ Laughs ]
It has no screen.
No battery.
-No apps.
-It has no features at all.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how it works.
Step one --
Pick it up.
Step two -- Hold it.
It's that simple!
[ Laughs ]
There's no warranty,
no returns,
and it's not intended
to be used for anything.
[ Laughs ]
With your help,
we can make the NoPhone
the Pet Rock
of our generation.
[ Laughs ]
Let's take
a quick group selfie
with the NoPhone's
latest addition,
"The Selfie Upgrade."
[ Laughs ]
It's a mirror.
[ Laughter ]
Sheldon:
Get it here, Lori.
Let's look
at some samples.
For Robert,
for you we have
the NoPhone
with the selfie upgrade.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, thank you.
Lori.
Mr. Wonderful, NoPhone
with the selfie upgrade.
Oh.
Let's do a selfie.
[ Laughing ]
And the instruction manual.
And here -- NoPhone
with selfie upgrade.
So, how many
have you sold?
We've sold over 3,100
since we've started
in November
of last year.
And one
out of every three people buy
the selfie upgrade.
Are you serious?
-Yeah.
-Oh, absolutely, yeah.
-3,100?
-We've 45 thou--
about $42,000 in sales
since we started.
Wow.
What does this cost
if you wanted to buy it?
$12 for the regular NoPhone,
and then $18 for the NoPhone
with the selfie upgrade.
-[ Laughs ]
-With the upgrade?
Cuban: How much does it cost you
to make them?
Right.
Right now the cost
to make it is $2.95.
Where have you sold them?
We sell it completely
at our online store, right now.
Online?
How did you guys come up
with this?
We were actually
at a rooftop bar,
and we were all staring at
our phones like we normally do.
And we looked up
from our phones,
and everyone in the bar was
also staring at their phones,
and we kind of like --
"This is crazy.
Everyone can not put
their phones down
for any point of the day."
And that's when we came up
with the idea for the NoPhone.
Um, yeah,
and we created a website,
and it was amazing.
The responses we received
all over the world,
they're like,
"My sister needs this.
My dad needs this."
[ Laughter ]
It's cute,
but I think pragmatically
it's never gonna be
a very big business.
It's like
I'm in an alternate world.
[ Laughter ]
I'm on the other side
where products are made
with absolutely no value.
While you're doing that,
I'm checking my messages.
[ Laughter ]
We're here
because we really think
we can make this a much bigger
thing with your help.
And, um --
Have you tried, uh, going
to a Spencer's
or something like that?
We haven't done a lot of that.
I mean, we both work.
We're advertising guys.
-No.
-Really?
You're kidding.
[ Laughter ]
So, sales is not our expertise,
and we will admit that.
I mean,
we, you know, we --
You wouldn't know
by your numbers.
You've made
hundreds of dollars.
[ Laughter ]
It's a gag gift.
Is that the bulk of the sales?
That's definitely one of the --
one of the --
one of the ways
we're going at it, and --
I'm serious when I ask you this,
and I'm really not joking...
-Right, right.
-...is there a patent on this?
[ Laughter ]
We've applied
for a provisional patent.
-No, you did not!
-We -- we did.
-We did it ourselves.
-Yeah, we did it ourselves.
Guys, there's only one thing
I hate more
than people staring
at their phones,
and that's
dumb patents.
And you know
what's really dumb?
A patent on a block of plastic.
I'm out.
-Thank you for your time.
-Thank you.
The thing is people --
Everybody knows somebody
that's addicted
to their smartphone, and --
Greiner: You know, there's
this motivational cat poster
that says, "Hang in there."
I'm sorry to say,
in this case,
I think the cat needs
to let go.
I'm not gonna invest
in this.
-We totally understand.
-I'm out.
-Lori, that's cruel.
-[ Laughs ]
What, come on, Robert.
Guys, I think --
I think it's really clever.
I mean,
you sold 3,100 units.
that's impressive.
My fear is that the 3,100 units
is the entire market.
That was only just
our store -- on one website.
Right, I mean,
imagine if we did,
you know, an infomercial
or something like that.
[ Laughter ]
-An infomercial!
-You can't --
Do not invest
more money in this.
-Are you kidding me?
-We've invested zero.
Guys, guys, I'm out.
Daymond?
I would just feel stupid
investing in this.
I'm sorry.
You're saying
it's poo-poo on a stick?
I don't --
I don't necessarily --
I don't think
anybody's business is that.
I think that
it could be a Pet Rock.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I'm out, guys.
O'Leary: Listen, the Pet Rock
was a piece of poo-poo, too.
This is poo-poo.
The best thing about this is
it's 3,100 units
and the product is
essentially nothing.
That's a very tough thing to do.
-It's not "essentially nothing."
It is nothing.
But we have managed to sell
nothing 3,100 times.
Look, guys, it's really bad --
really bad.
I'm out.
All right.
Y'all have a good one.
-Congrats, guys.
-Thank you.
-Thanks.
-Congrats.
[ Laughs ]
Gould:
You know, the Sharks,
they missed
a huge opportunity here.
This is the NoPhone.
It's the Pet Rock
of our generation.
It's something that --
You know,
it's not just a piece a plastic.
Well, it is
a piece of plastic,
but it's gonna be
a revolution.
Narrator: Next into the tank is
a high-tech way to stay handy.
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Jason Neubauer.
And I'm Chris Stoikos.
Our company is Coolbox.
And today,
we're here seeking
$500,000 for a 10% stake
in our company.
The toolbox has been around
for over 100 years,
and no one has been able
to significantly innovate it.
We're here
to do just that.
We have smartphones,
smart cars, and smart TVs.
Why wouldn't you want
a smarter toolbox?
Sharks,
I'd like to introduce you
to the world's first
smart toolbox, the Coolbox.
The Coolbox has
a very vast feature set.
It has a power cord
that warps around the back,
allows you to plug
into a socket,
and it activates
the pass-through power points
that go down the side.
Our two latches are
very rugged.
Lift it up, we have
a whiteboard allowing you
to take notes
on the inside.
This is just dead space
on every other toolbox
that's actually
out there.
Turn on our light, pop it out,
put it anywhere you want.
We have an iPad stand
and a iPhone stand
that allows you to stand up
when you're inside of here.
You can put an iPad,
look at notes while you're
actually working on it.
On the top, we also have
another iPad stand
or an iPhone stand depending
on if it's opened or closed.
The lid is magnetic.
You can toss
all your screws, bolts,
and spare parts on there
when you're actually working
on the job site.
We have two USB ports
that allow you
to charge iPhones, iPads.
We have our clock.
We have our bottle opener,
which we absolutely love,
'cause we all get thirsty
from time to time while
we're working.
And then
our favorite part yet,
the wireless,
Bluetooth speakers.
Wow.
You got everything in there.
We've got it all.
So, Sharks, we got
the nuts and bolts figured out.
Which one of you guys wants
to lock up an investment
and make the Coolbox
a household name?
What do you make that for,
and what do you sell it for?
Right now,
our cost is $110.
We're really looking
to get that down a lot lower.
We've presold them for $190,
but on --
When we're actually retailing
them in stores,
they're gonna be $249.
John: How many
have you presold?
We did a little
over $370,000 in presales.
Have you shipped yet
to anybody?
We have not. I'm actually
still kind of jet-lagged.
I just got back from China
two nights ago.
We were visiting
our factories there, setting up.
They've just begun
to dug the tools.
-I love the idea...
-Yep.
...but your cost is
very high,
your margins aren't
very good,
and you don't even have
retail yet or distribution,
and you're saying the business
is worth $5 million today.
We actually have
a huge order from Lowe's,
an 8,000-unit order
from them,
hat we want to do
an exclusive with --
-Ah! There's the other shoe.
-So, 8,000, 8,000 --
You have an 8,000-unit order.
It's a firm sale?
No, they didn't.
They just basically --
They have intent to buy.
They said,
"Come back as soon as" --
What does that mean,
"intent to buy"?
We said we can ship to you guys
at the end of September.
They said they want to do
a Q4 exclusive with us.
We said we're --
-So, why wouldn't you just say,
"Yes, done.
Give me the purchase order."
And then go factored,
get it factored.
Greiner: Right.
'Cause they don't give purchase
orders more than two months out.
So when are they gonna give you
the purchase order?
We're about --
about 30 days away.
Yeah, we're looking
to ship these units
at the end of September.
How long is the exclusive for
with those guys?
Just Q4.
We actually had extreme interest
from Stanley Black & Decker.
I mean, the licensing of the
opportunity is huge for us.
Guys, this is obviously
a capital-intensive business.
How much have you guys put in?
Have you raised money?
Give us
kind of the scoop.
No, we haven't.
That's what we need.
We put in $50,000
of our own money to
bootstrap this thing.
We need help
on the money side.
We need people to put this in
so that we can put these orders
and start rolling
so that when we go to Lowe's
in these meetings,
we're saying, "Yes.
We can deliver these
within 60 days."
Do you have a patent
on this?
Yeah, we have
a provisional patent right now.
What's the patent on?
It can't be just --
Utility -- all of the
different features combined
into one toolbox.
So nobody else can put
Bluetooth speakers in a toolbox?
It's the combination.
It's the Bluetooth speakers,
the USB ports, the lights,
the magnetic lid,
the iPad stand.
Greiner: Well,
let me ask you a question.
-Yeah.
-Let's say that somebody makes
a toolbox that doesn't have
a magnetic top
but has speakers.
-I think, at the end of the day,
you really do want
to establish a brand go for --
I think at any point
you could --
So, how are you going
to license it
to Black & Decker? They're
gonna rip it off in a second.
No, they're --
We were just there.
I was in Israel visiting
their head office.
They have a head of storage
and tools.
Because we're the first ones
in this market,
we have the ability
to be able to, you know,
create and shift and move
with newer innovations.
How much money did you sink
into making the molds overseas?
All told, it's gonna be
about $250,000.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, so,
how are you gonna pay
for the inventory
to deliver these?
That's why we weren't able
to give Lowe's a definitive
because you never want to
bite off more than you can chew.
I understand --
-So how many units do you have
to ship
for your $375,000?
Uh, we have to ship
2,200 units.
So, how are you gonna
pay for the inventory
for the 2,200 units?
We're raising a total round
of $1 million, right now.
Oh, with others?
[ All groan ]
The million-dollar route
we were gonna do
at a $4 million
valuation.
You need $250,000
right now to just fulfill
your obligation
to all the people
that have placed orders.
-Correct.
You said you kind of have
contacts at Black & Decker,
'cause I'm interested
in a licensing play here.
But I really believe
that you think
that you're worth $5 million,
and that's not the case.
I'm gonna have to bring you down
to a realistic number.
My offer is $500,000 for 25%,
but I want to license this.
Okay.
Thank you.
Are there -- Are there maybe --
Hear some other offers?
Herjavec: Chris, let me --
Jason, let me tell you --
I loved it
when you first came in.
Um, at the price point
you're at, at $240 --
I mean, toolboxes are
$20, $30, $35.
They don't have
all the functionality,
but I don't think
people care.
We're not comparing
to those toolboxes.
When you're blue-collar,
you're nitty-gritty,
you want to go in.
You want to touch this thing.
You want to be able to see it
when it's on the actual shelf.
I don't know, man.
If you're blue collar,
are you gonna spend that kind
of money on a toolbox --
240 bucks -- because
it has speakers in it?
Guys spend $200
on their speakers.
They spend $50
on their Coolbox.
All of these things
actually together costs
upwards of $400
when you buy these things.
And this is something
that every one of them has
in their actual toolkit
when they go to the job site.
You know what?
My dad was a blue collar guy.
He just wanted a toolbox
that was sturdy and it worked.
He didn't want
all the other crap in it.
He would have never spent
$240 bucks on a toolbox.
I see
a lot of challenges.
I don't want to go down
that road with you.
I'm out.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Thanks, Robert.
O'Leary: You know
what I'm worried about?
You feel that you're gonna
be successful in retail.
We haven't seen
sell-through yet.
Every time
you inventory one of those
into a big box retailer,
you need one to display,
'cause people have
to see it,
and then maybe two or three
that are in inventory
to support sell-through.
That's gonna tie up
a ton of cash.
I mean, this is why
it's a license deal.
Yeah, maybe, but --
You need somebody else
to take all that.
I don't think
a licensee, either,
isn't going
to ignore that risk.
This is
a very capital-intensive --
John: But a licensee like
a Black & Decker
who already has the space --
Yeah, but they're the ones
that are gonna want
complete patent protection,
'cause they're
not gonna take it out.
'Cause I don't see
how you patent this.
Stoikos: Correct,
which is what -- They're looking
at our patent right now,
but, Kevin, how many times
has somebody told you
the things that you're doing
are completely risky and
you've gone on your own and --
And those are
always the best businesses.
Of course, those are
the best businesses.
-Look, I --
-And not that --
O'Leary: I've learned something
about a business
that's capital-intensive.
The more successful you are,
the more capital it ties up.
And the risk is
always as you're running
and you're growing,
you're tying up more capital.
Then, something changes
in the market,
another box comes out
that becomes popular
at a lower price,
and all of a sudden
your inventory becomes
less valuable.
That's the risk
I see here.
I'm out.
I mean, we're here looking
for a partner, you know?
And at the end of the day,
like, that is --
Herjavec:
Well, you've got a partner.
Daymond's offered you
$500,000 for 25%...
-Of course, but we're also --
-...contingent on licensing.
We still haven't heard
from everybody yet.
Have a bigger round.
Not everybody --
I'd love to hear what...
-What are you doing, Mark?
...Mark and Lori have to say.
-The more Sharks drop out,
I become more valuable.
Um...
Cuban: Well, guys, let me help
carry things along here.
I rarely, rarely
ever discuss valuation, right?
Because if I think
a company's gonna grow,
it's all gonna wash out
long-term.
But you guys are really
at a very precarious point
right now, you know?
And that's what concerns me
more than anything,
because the worst thing
that can happen
to a start-up company is
to make a commitment
and not be able to live up
to it and fulfill.
And, yeah, you're going
out to raise money,
but you're desperate,
you know?
And you're not pricing like
you're desperate.
Well, to be honest, we haven't
even started with it.
This is the first place
we've came.
A lot of the times, you don't
just invest in the product.
You invest in the people.
Is the Coolbox the best idea
in the entire world?
Of course not.
There are, you know,
ideas all over the place.
Do we believe in it,
and do we believe it's a product
that we've put blood,
sweat, and tears into
for the last six months?
Yes, we do.
Have we had other companies
where we've struggled
and bounced our way
back up to the top
and kept the people
that are impressed with us
and invest with us happy?
Yes.
What's gonna make you
get involved, Mark?
Where are your lack
of confidences?
The lack of confidence is
there's nothing
that's protectable.
That's the part
that keeps me away
because you could be going
full speed ahead,
but then someone could
just knock you off,
and it's gone.
[ Snaps fingers ]
And that's my hesitancy.
I'm out.
Two Sharks left.
Now, the risk you have is
if Lori goes out,
Daymond may adjust his offer,
'cause he's greedy.
And so maybe
you should accept it now
before you find out the outcome
of what Lori's gonna do.
-I'm willing to take a risk.
-There's a fair amount of risk
right now in the Shark Tank.
-And I hope that maybe
hopefully they both like
each other,
and maybe they want
to work together.
Oh, you want to take
that gamble?
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Jason and Chris have
one offer on the table
from Daymond for their
high-tech toolbox, Coolbox.
But they have yet to hear
from Lori.
O'Leary: Now the risk
you have is if Lori goes out,
Daymond may adjust his offer,
'cause he's greedy.
Do you want to take
that gamble?
Do you want
to tighten up your offer
and give us a little bit
of a better valuation?
Neubauer: Or is there any way
to do it without, I mean --
I really not want an investment
tied on the licensing.
It's not
that I'm not open to it.
I just would not like that tied
to the investment.
Okay.
Take your chances with Lori.
Greiner: since "Shark Tank,"
I find that I am very heavily
in the hardware space,
unusually --
Scrub Daddy, ScreenMend,
FiberFix --
so I'm all over
Home Depot, Lowe's,
Ace, True Value,
these places.
So, this can fit
within my family
of entrepreneurs.
The thing -- I agree with
Daymond and the other Sharks.
We don't know yet
if the market's going
to pay that much money
for this.
So, for me
to give you an offer,
I feel I would need...
I would give you
the $500,000.
But I'd need a 30%.
-Ohh.
-Whoa.
-Good think you waited.
-Not contingent --
Not contingent on licensing.
-How about that power drill,
kids?
-But --
-I'd say it was deep.
-I feel --
I'm gonna make it contingent
on one thing.
It's that Lowe's,
for sure, is going
to be giving you
a purchase order.
Yeah.
All right, Chris, Jason,
you got two offers. Both
have a contingency.
I'm gonna recant
my offer.
I'm out.
-Whoa.
Lori, let's go
$500,000 for 20%.
We have these sales
right now.
Through, like we telling you,
all these P.O.s.
And, again,
it's contingent upon that.
You can come
to the next meeting.
We'll go over to North Carolina
and meet with the buyer.
We'll check out
all the different spots...
Shh.
I'll give you $500,000
as a line of credit,
which is a loan,
at 5% interest,
and then I'll get
15% equity in the company.
Final offer?
Final offer.
Want to do it?
Let's do it.
Let's do it. We accept.
-Let's do it.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
That was a lot harder
than I thought it was gonna be.
Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
-You guys are tough, man.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations, guys.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Uh-huh.
[ Exhales sharply ]
All right, bud.
Good job.
Neubauer: I think
striking a deal with Lori
elevates us
to the next level.
I mean, there's certain things
in relationship experience
that we don't have,
and she just gives us
basically
that checkmark box
and validation of where we're at
and where we're going.